I think plants present an opportunity
for people to look closely at something
and get invested in something that's
truly very much outside of themselves.
Plants are not like us and the more you
study plants,
the more different and deep ways you see
that they are not like us.
All the important things that we do from
how we
move around to how we reproduce to how
we
react to the sun.
Any human activity you could point to,
hey,
you're going to see something very
different in plants and the more you
know about how plants function and the
more you watch them function and test
their functioning,
the more deeply you understand how
different they are.
I think that's useful because I think
people have a need to transcend
themselves.
And I know that when I get bogged down
in,
um,
the dysfunctionalities of how people
treat each other and conflicts between
men and women and,
and money problems in science and all
this kind of thing that I can,
uh,
take some comfort and joy and
transcending what seemed like very small
scale human noise.
And look at
the differences and a life form.
That's been successfully occupying the
planet for 400 million years,
so quite frankly,
I get a lot of joy and comfort and
happiness from considering these things.
I mean,
I think that's the main reason to do
sciences,
that it feeds the soul.
I think that,
and I see this in students year after
year,
that the more you know about the world,
the more you feel like you're part of it
and it's like nothing else.
You know,
you teach somebody not to just walk by a
tree but to look up at it and say,
Yep,
that one's deciduous and that one's
evergreen and that one is going to lose
it sleeves this fall,
but that one's going to stay green.
Just very basic things like that and you
see people sense of self and self esteem
rise and all of a sudden they know
something about the world that they
journey through and it makes them a
little bit bigger as a person and that's
really a wonderful thing to watch in
students and to be able to facilitate.
So I think
we should plant trees not to save trees.
I think planning a tree is
not unlikely to be a method you use to
save yourself and to find meaning and
something that will be with you and grow
with you
and be something you can come back to
and contrast your own life with.
I'm very influenced by some research
that came out,
I think in the eighties that compared
retention during learning.
And I remember very strongly that the
main result of that was the,
the larger,
the number of senses that you invoked if
you were touching something,
if you were writing and listening and
watching and even smelling something or
tasting,
you know,
the more senses that you could engage
during learning the more effectively
that information was integrated into the
person and learned,
I think with digital media,
we're very,
very strongly going towards a medium
that is visual only.
I mean,
you do hear the message,
etc. But I worry that it's a passive
stance just in terms of using the five
senses and that,
um,
you can't learn passively.
I think the Best learning is done with
active manipulatIon.
Um,
and we need to be able to work with our
hands.
you know,
it's not just about using our brains.
I mean,
eventually we have to manipulate the
world with our hands in order to make
tangible change,
right?
And,
um,
students need practice with that.
Kids need practice with that.
We need to do that in life.
And uh,
for better or worse,
you know,
our screen experiences will never,
never give us that.
It's very important to put children in
an environment where they can take
things apart,
uh,
where they can break things and then
learn to fix them where they can trust
their hands and know
their capacity to manipulate objects.
And I see that as a much more active
interaction than what the newer types of
technology offer as they supply
learning.
So,
you know,
I'm not anti
screen,
et cetera,
but I do worry that the hours we spend
that way are replacing some of the
things that are going to be important.